[Musique]
tous les vendredis jeu sort de taule
vers 17 heures je sors du plus grand
centre de détention pour femmes de
france à rennes
je viens de passer l'après-midi avec des
femmes qui ont attaqué des femmes qui
ont arnaqué des femmes qui ont tué et je
viens de passer une chouette après-midi
pour arriver jusqu'à elle je décline mon
nom je donne ma carte d'identité je
passe une grille une barrière
je mets toutes mes affaires dans un
casier
je passe sous un portique comme à
l'aéroport il ya des sas des bips des
clés des portes des gardiens en uniforme
partout
moi je suis journaliste et j'anime la
rédaction de citadel citadelle c'est un
magazine trimestriel qui est entièrement
écrit et illustré par des femmes
détenues en longues peines
tout ça derrière les barreaux quand on
m'a proposé de participer à ce projet
moi j'avoue que je m'attendais à
rencontrer des femmes tristes et
agressive
vous entendez vous entendez cette voix
dans ma tête qu'ils disaient ces femmes
ne peuvent être que triste et agressive
alors moi je pensais que ma mission se
serait de les occuper
elles ont un passé moche douloureux
table où elles ont à présent que
personne n'a envie de vivre d'amour et
un futur lointain un certain tabou aussi
donc moi je rentrais pour les divertir
pour leur faire oublier le temps notre
projet devait durer un an
trois numéros ça fait six ans que j'y
vais j'ai vu passer une soixantaine de
rédactrices et six ans où j'ai appris
que faire ce numéro faire ce magazine ça
leur sert pas du tout à oublier le temps
au contraire ça leur sert à se
réapproprier leur présent six ans où
j'ai appris que chaque jour on a le
droit de devenir quelqu'un d'autre
en arrêtant de laisser le passé tout
conditionné dans notre rédaction il ya
des ordinateurs mais il n'ya pas
d'internet il ya pas de téléphone
il ya pas de chaînes d'info en direct il
n'y a pas de sortie un reportage
possible pas d'appareil photo
avant j'aurais dit bas donc il n'ya pas
de journal on fait avec ce qu'on a
on part des rédactrices des femmes en
conférence de rédaction
moi je leur demande qu'est ce qui vous
intéresse en ce moment qu'est ce qui
vous motive qu'est-ce qui vous indigne
qu'est ce qui vous met en colère de quoi
vous avez envie de parler
bettina matinale à une queue de cheval
elle adore la littérature et la zumba
bettina elle veut une interviewe et
marina carrère d'encausse
au sujet de ses romans hélène elle elle
veut faire un sujet sur l'alcoolisme au
féminin et la haine c'est une excellente
râleuse et c'est une excellente poète v
iata est venue interviewer djamel pour
se marrer elle dit parce que ici sa vie
devient vite morbide pied aux 6m dit si
on pouvait interviewer des beaux mecs
parce que quitte à faire rentrer des
gens en prison pour les interviewer
autant que ce soit des beaux mecs et
iata et les cash mais veillez à ta elle
est hyper juste quand ces femmes devront
chercher en elle qui elles sont au
présent elles produisent des
informations valables
elles produisent des informations
inédites un article sur les conditions
de travail en détention à parce que il
faut travailler et gagner sa croûte en
prison un article sur les bébés de la
pouponnière du centre pénitentiaire à
parce qu'il ya des bébés qui vivent et
qui naissent en prison pour écrire pour
dessiner ces femmes est réfléchie elle
écoute l écoute leur élan elle écoute
leurs envies et quand elles font ça moi
je les voir devenir auteur de qui elles
sont parce qu'elle reprenne les rênes de
leur vie imaginez imaginez que votre
journée soit programmée par quelqu'un
d'autre que vous du matin hausse
à lever activités travail rapport avec
votre famille ateliers soins médicaux
imaginez votre planning il vous échappe
complètement comme ça arrive aux enfants
ben vous comprenez que pour elle choisir
être maîtresse d'un processus
un article indécent de a à z le mener
jusqu'au bout à leur rythme
ça a énormément de valeur alors quand
elle écrit bettina elle se fait plaisir
quand elle écrit v iata et cherché
creuse et à découvre quand elle écrit
hélène on aimait sa colère à distance
thérèse thérèse à l'élu style très
sensible à la planète et aux animaux
elle a interviewé pierre rabhi thérèse
et résultats comme sa citadelle m'a
permis de comprendre que j'existais que
j'étais capable d'aller chercher des
informations en moi des bonnes idées que
j'étais capable de les exprimer des
choses que j'avais enfoui depuis
longtemps et moi ce que j'adore c'est
comment les personnages les personnes
interviewées les beaux mecs mais pas que
comment ces personnes interviewées elles
réagissent à ça quand elle rentre en
détention elles sont comme vous comme
moi et c'est normal elle avait mis les
prisonnières dans une case à cause de
leur passé et quand elle les voit c'est
quand les gens les voient intelligente
enthousiaste bain et ressortent un peu
sonné et disney attendait ces femmes
ça pourrait être ma voisine ça pourrait
être ma soeur ça pourrait être moi
quand elle se réapproprie qui elles sont
au présent les rédactrices je vois qu'il
se passe aussi autre chose je vois
qu'elle accepte leur présent tel qu'il
est un article sur comment on garde des
liens avec ses enfants quand on les voit
jamais un article sur comment on bricole
un cadeau de noël de récup à partir de
rien parce qu'on a rien sous la main
elles écrivent noir sur blanc dans le
magazine que leur présent aujourd'hui
c'est ça et c'est pas une souris
acceptés sont présents c'est pas rien ça
veut dire qu'on accepte son passé on
accepte d'en être responsable et ça veut
dire qu'on accepte pour que pour le
futur en faites pas on a le choix
on a le choix même de redevenir ou de
devenir fier de soi quand elle commence
l'atelier les rédactrices elles disent
toutes un an mais moi je sais pas
dessiner
ah non mais moi je sais pas je ne sais
pas écrire je sais pas faire vous
entendez vous entendez cette petite voix
dans leur tête qui leur à bhp nul des
mauvaises tattoo gâchette à tout casser
et ben quand elle ne tienne le magazine
dans les mains quand il sort touche chez
l'imprimeur et qu'elle voit qu'elles
sont capables de faire une belle revue
qu'elles sont capables d'intéresser les
gens d'offrir des articles d'offrir des
analyses et bien elles sont fières
d'elles est souvent c'est la première
fois depuis longtemps et elle se
redresse alors moi dans cette rédaction
en prison j'ai appris pour de vrai qu'on
n'est pas conditionnée par son passé
alors je veux pas dire que ces femmes
aient devrait oublier leurs actes passés
non je veux dire que même même quand on
a commis le pire
li rattrapable irréversible il ya un
après un après on a le choix d'agir et
de marcher vers une autre direction
on a le choix de souffler sur la partie
de soirée bones qui est sage et moi je
le vois là bas que plus on souffle sur
cette partie
a plus cette partie là et s'allume et ça
c'est à notre portée à tous chaque jour
alors ce que je suis en train de vous
dire là l'air de rien en fait je suis en
train de vous dire que marianne qui a
vendu de la drogue à des enfants elle a
encore le droit d'être fière d'elle
ouais ouais
et ça c'est la chose étrange qui m'est
arrivé à citadelle la magie de notre
rédaction
c'est que on est tous dans le même
bateau on est toutes à égalité entre
humaine
on est tellement occupé à boucler des
papiers un magazine dont on soit fier et
à rigoler et à réfléchir que les
jugements et les étiquettes tout ça
s'efface naturellement les jugements
vous savez ces petites voix qui nous
ressert la tête qui nous ressert le
coeur beaucoup de rédactrice de
citadelle ne me disent pas pourquoi
elles sont en prison
moi je leur demande pas parce que je
trouve que ce qu'on vit au présent
ensemble que ce qu'elles sont devenues
aujourd'hui
maintenant la chope la façon dont elles
choisissent de se comporter
tout ça ça a beaucoup plus de valeur
pour moi que leur passé et je me suis
rendu compte que plus
j'oublie de les juger plus je donne de
l'importance au présent mais j'ai pas
toujours penser comme ça il ya un truc
que je vous ai faite avant de commencer
ce travail là en prison j'ai travaillé
et j'ai enquêté pendant longtemps sur le
viol en france
plusieurs de mes amis proches ont été
touchés et moi à cette époque là j'étais
hyper en colère j'étais en colère que
ruth retroussé violeur je voulais je
crois que je voulais que les gens qui
ont fait souffrir d'autres ne soient
plus jamais heureux qu'ils aient plus
loin d'être re plus jamais et puis je me
suis retrouvé en prison avec les
criminels sympa attachante aimable bah
là j'ai bugué ma colère ma colère elle
était légitime
ma colère elle était née c
ferme m mais en prison je me suis rendu
compte que je n'étais pas obligé de me
limiter à ça que je pouvais continuer le
chemin que peut-être les gens qui nous
ont fait souffrir on perd du temps et on
perd de l'énergie à les haïr à
s'enfermer avec eux dans le passé ça les
rend même pas meilleure et nous est ce
que ça nous permet d'avancer alors que
si on cesse de les condamner on leur
donne un espace un espace où ils ont le
choix de devenir la chouette personnes
qu'ils peuvent être et nous aussi
vous entendez vous entendez toute
l'importance qu'on donne au présent
quand on laisse tomber jugement moi j'ai
trouvé ça très très libérateur juger les
actes n'est pas juger les gens
je dois oublier de le faire à peu près
de dix fois par jour
c'est pas grave parce que j'ai trouvé un
truc qui me motive - je les juge
moi je me juge plus je les accepte comme
elles sont aujourd'hui plus je m'accepte
moi aussi comme je suis aujourd'hui si
elles peuvent rebondir après leur passé
alors moi aussi quand je me suis planté
caen j'ai fait un mauvais choix je peux
rebondir aussi je suis pas nul j'ai de
la valeur encore et c'est même à cette
valeur là que je peux me raccrocher
alors la prochaine fois que vous et moi
en jugera ou qu'on se jugera durement
est-ce qu'on pourrait reconnaître cette
petite voix qui donne beaucoup trop
d'importance au passé est-ce qu'on
pourrait revenir au présent à tout ce
qui est possible à tout ce qui est
ouvert
maintenant la prochaine fois qu'on dira
je vaux plus rien je me le pardonnerai
jamais à cause du passé est ce qu'on
pourrait penser à thérèse avait iata à
hélène habib tina est ce qu'on pourrait
penser aux rédactrices de citadelle
c'est rédactrice de citadelle qui ont
osé sollicité la garde des sceaux pour
une interview par téléphone sur
l'inégalité homme-femme dans
et prison des femmes condamnées par la
justice
la garde des sceaux madame belloubet
elle n'a pas accepté l'entretien par
téléphone elle s'y déplacer à
l'intérieur de la prison pour répondre
aux questions des rédactrices merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]